is Dragon Ball super xanimation any good
is the question that one might see
littered throughout various forums where
I am absolutely certain polite discourse
takes place the animation is an iffy
thing but even as recently as a few
years ago I found it exceedingly
difficult to define what exactly good
animation even was I knew it had to do
with how the show looked but I had no
idea what constituted as specifically
terrible or specifically exceptional
when it came to watching something that
was animated many people have spoken on
the topic of Dragon Balls animation but
I don't think many have spoken about
what makes the show specifically good or
bad and how the show is doing now it's
very easy to jump onto the bandwagon
blindly agreeing with what the popular
consensus is but today I plan to go
against the grain and while I personally
can't name most animators working on
specific scenes just by looking at it I
do have a qualification in animation and
that has to be worth something this is a
subject I found even animation teachers
have difficulty fully explaining but I'm
gonna try my best so let's find out if
Dragon Ball super xanimation is any good
god bless my disliked barren comment
section if I were to put these two
pieces of media next to each other which
one would you be inclined to say has the
best animation while some of you out
there might be rolling your eyes I'm
sure some of you might have actually
chosen the one on the left but in
actuality the stick figure has better
animation by virtue of the fact that
it's actually moving or animated this
might seem obvious for some but before
moving forward I want to have everyone
at least on the same page with regards
what to look for animation is in my
opinion one of the most wondrous and
incredible forms of entertainment ever
created with a blank canvas you can
illustrate our paint absolutely anything
you're hired or dreams desired animation
then takes those drawings and breathes
life into them in an incredibly real way
but when it comes to good animation and
what to look for it like most everything
else in the arts is pretty subjective
but with that subjectivity there are
elements of objectivity sprinkled
throughout I mean why else would shows
like attack on Titan and one punch men
be universally praised for their
animation while scenes from Naruto and
Dragonball become universally panned for
their efforts in short there can be
objectively poorly animated sequences to
best break down why this happens we need
look at three different types of 2d
animation now before I proceed there
aren't just three types of animation to
be aware of the same way there aren't
just three primary colors there's room
for infinite variation in nuance within
this very general framework and with
that small disclaimer out of the way
let's look at our first topic when I
think of realistic or detailed anime
what comes to mind are films like ghost
in the shell' not the live-action film
and Makoto Shinkai is 2016 mega-hit your
name well there are other movies I could
probably think of that better fit this
title these are the films that
immediately sprung forth from my brain
and I think there's a reason for that
these are all story driven films at
their core and while detailed and
realistic they all utilize animation in
very different ways to enhance their own
stories in the case of Mamoru Oshii x'
1995 film ghost in the shell' the movie
establishes itself as a gritty visceral
take on the sci-fi genre and it's that
gritty realistic take that gives the
film its sense of tension and excitement
this is made all the more clear in one
of the final scenes when major Kusanagi
combats the spider tank because of the
film's animation we the viewer receive a
clear understanding that this world and
its characters react very similarly to
our own as opposed to shows like Looney
Tunes whose worlds whole point is that
nothing is the way it seems and so
despite it being just a robot with some
guns going up against her main character
the tension is very real as we know
their respective limitations as viewers
not everything needs being struggles to
create stakes it's all about perspective
on the opposite side of this section
comes makoto shinkai is your name
while ghost in the shell' was primarily
an action thriller your name is a
slice-of-life fantasy romance starring
two main characters talking and meets
aha as they swap bodies numerous times
over the course of the film the primary
focus of your names animation is to
convey emotion as effectively as
possible
there are numerous means to create a sad
or emotional scene but regarding
animation your name achieves this
through subtle and in some cases very
subtle character movements it's clear
that the characters movements were
meticulously drawn to convey as much
emotion and information as possible to
the viewer without any context you can
clearly tell that this is me too huh
inhabiting takis body through the
movement
alone this is a textbook example of
fantastic character acting its choices
like these that make the characters feel
surreal and ultimately that's the
connection most animation wants to
achieve at the end of the day a
connection to the characters this is the
section you'll find dragon ball one
punch man Naruto and we demo Shonen
anime occupying it marries a realistic
detail approach with softer exaggerated
sequences that usually help convey
comedic intent or aid in the flow of
motion for action sequences but and this
is important there is a limit to how
exaggerated a sequence can get before
crosses the line and takes you out of
the story that's being told
unless that craziness is established
early on in the show that threshold is
important to keep in mind I'll touch on
this again later now working within
those limitations can yield spectacular
results to achieve this speed lines or
smears can be very effective as when
it's played in normal speed it helps the
sequence look more energetic or smooth
depending on what you're going for this
is very much common practice which shows
like Dragon Ball where there is a fight
almost every episode another good
example of this and probably the best
textbook example would come from PI Q's
fourth o P in the latter stages it's
clear that the action is ramped up on
top of exaggerating the motions of the
characters involved you'll notice the
use of smears also as you can see this
is an effective way of conveying the
intensity or speed of movement and you
might have noticed that talking about
super also utilizes these techniques
shin-chan space dandy and miss ER osa
Matsu are just some of the many crazy
animated shows that have seemingly no
boundaries when it comes to their
respective animation styles despite the
fact that all of these animated shows
are actually quite different so if you
want crazy unyielding psychedelic
animated sequences then these shows are
for you and this section is for you
maybe try mobs like a 100 also that show
is gorgeous nothing is too over-the-top
and nothing is too bombastic this
exaggerated style specifically works
well for comedic shows where comedy
takes the front seat over action and
drama while shows like Dragon Ball might
be considered comedies they are first
and foremost shown in action stories and
that distinction is important giggle
creasing Lee made a video discussing a
certain infamous scene between Naruto
and pain there
a lot of discussion regarding that scene
and in short while it's clear a lot of
work went into the animation for that
sequence it crossed that threshold I
spoke about earlier it went too far into
exaggeration and thus didn't match the
Naruto series anymore
taking the viewers out of the action and
into a critical mindset it began to look
like a different show entirely how would
you feel if your name or Dragonball
suddenly in its most important moment
shifted and looked like a different show
entirely remember animations job
primarily is to transport you through
the story while using techniques to
enhance it not to distract from it
because at the end of the day the most
important thing about a film is its
story distracting from that can ruin the
experience in most cases now this isn't
true for every show as every show has a
different threshold I could see one
punch man getting away with something
like this jutsu the show's light-hearted
nature however Dragon Ball super it
suffered from the same issues as Naruto
the series had objective trouble in the
early days that garnered a ton of bad
press for the show it trended worldwide
and even Forbes covered it nowadays
people who haven't seen the show's
quality for the last number of years
will still consider Dragon Ball super a
poorly animated disaster when really
that's not the case and it hasn't been
for years but people still say it and
consistently stand by it too in the
early days much of supers animation that
came under scrutiny came from a former
Dragon Ball Z key animator no quítate
let me be the first to say that he
personally is one of my favorite
animators on the show from an animation
purist point of view he produces
fantastic fluid work consistently and
honestly very few can match his efforts
in the series when it comes to pure
movement there are other animators
working on the show that I personally do
not like at all but I have specifically
chosen Tata due to his polarizing style
because there is an argument to be made
that now quítate although great his
loose style might not suit the Dragon
Ball art style that fans and viewers of
the series have come to expect and much
of Dragon Ball super is flack from a
visual standpoint stems from that
sentiment but I hear you asking why did
this happen he's talented and has a long
history with the show dating back to
Dragon Ball Z well Dragon Balls
animation had a bigger focus on a
comedic style and thus it's round soft
designs
simple animations suited the tone of the
show was going for as the ears
progressed so too did Toriyama stylin
either by chance or by design
Dragon Ball Z's more serious darker
themes were complemented by an edgier
art style in animation practice it just
so happened that Dragon Ball Z
specifically became hugely popular and
as a result that Dragon Ball Z became a
dragon ball was and meant to the vast
majority of fans and the general public
ask anyone what they know about Dragon
Ball and they will mention super sands
or giant bean struggles way more often
than they will the pilaf saga or Goku
training with Master Roshi I mean
there's a reason why the new game is
called fire Z and not super fighters or
something and that's not because those
moments in early Dragon Balls don't
appeal to a wide number of people it's
just that Dragon Ball Z cemented itself
in the minds of the majority as what
Dragon Ball is and understanding that I
think is the key to all this in the eyes
of a lot of people Dragon Ball Z is all
that matters and the further they
differentiate themselves from Dragon
Ball Z the more pushback there will be
and this is where those animation types
we were talking about earlier on come in
now quítate and much of Dragon Ball
super early on did not match the vision
fans had in their heads
it was softer more exaggerated and had a
greater focus on comedy I think it would
be fair to also state that if suddenly
Dragon Ball super adopted an art style
similar to say ghost in the shell' the
backlash would be enormous because that
style while brilliant isn't what fans
recognize as being Dragon Ball Dragon
Ball - Dragon Ball Z had a much easier
transition from a visual point of view
for a number of reasons
Dragon Ball was a story of Goku as a
child tool 18 and Dragon Ball Z was Goku
story as an adult and with that age
shift came a seamless asked of evolution
through the years Dragon Ball super had
the misfortune of following easily one
of the most important and successful
animes ever in Dragon Ball Z sprinklin a
17-year long hiatus and while these
animated sequences are great the
nostalgia wanted this and it's that
disconnect that causes that frustration
from a visual standpoint
I think from a technical point of view
its animation is great
it's a shame many fans dismiss Dragon
Ball super visual without giving it a
second thought these days because
despite being in the middle of an action
heavy arc the series is in a fantastic
place when it comes to animation artwork
and consistency overall every episode
looks perfectly fine - amazing
my favorite moment even comes from now
quítate a guy you might have thought I
was ragging on but honestly produces
top-notch work ignoring the bad
animation the series suffered at the
beginning because there's really no sign
of it anymore
Dragon Ball super produces spectacular
animated sequences on a regular basis
some that are nostalgic and others that
are innovative and for a show that has
such a long history to be able to show
me things I haven't seen before is that
the very least I feel worth a second
chance and trust me I'm not just saying
that because I like the show I'm saying
that because the animation genuinely is
fantastic Dragon Ball isn't perfect but
neither is animation or creativity in
general if there was a be all to end all
solution to the perfect show or animated
sequence that animation and
entertainment in general would cease to
be creative and become more of a
mathematical equation
not to mention boring that's the beauty
of animation and art in general it's
anything that you want it to be growing
up watching a series is very different
to jumping into it later in life nothing
will ever capture the emotional feeling
your younger self had again and coming
to terms with that is both a sobering
and
admittedly a sad concept but only
through understanding that can you move
forward and look at modern series with a
more critical and fair eye and it's that
I feel is Dragon Ball super is biggest
disadvantage nowadays as I've
demonstrated before the show looks
sensational now arguably producing
better work than Dragon Ball Z at times
if you look at it fairly and that was
the goal of this video to get you
looking at the material fairly rather
than blindly dismissing a show that has
clearly improved just because everyone
else does look at it yourself and be
honest about how you feel and don't
worry about what everyone else is saying
no one can claim that objectively Dragon
Ball super is a poorly animated show
anymore the same way no one can say that
objectively Dragon Ball super is a
failure because it all boils down to
each individual viewers unique
experiences with the characters and the
story
so if Dragon Ball soup
is your favorite show than to you it is
a success and you don't need some guy on
a youtube video to clarify that for you
or at least you shouldn't